Hello everyone, just getting started a couple more minutes see if anybody pops on all right so we'll get started at them. I'll just add people as we go here.
I hope everybody had a good weekend. I had an interesting weekend. My dog had three seizures yesterday. So my heart is a little bit broken and I'm extremely tired. So if I seem off today it's because I definitely am.
Got very little sleep the last few nights, but she's doing all right. Gonna bring her in for more testing this afternoon. So we're hoping everything.
Everything pans out and who knows we'll see. Anyways, so I hope you guys all had a good weekend.
All right, I'm going to share the screen here and hang on one second. I'm on a different computer. So it's making me do something different that I haven't seen. Okay, maybe I need to check that.
Sorry guys hang on.
Okay, I guess I can't share the screen. I don't know how to figure it out right now. Of course, of all times to make me try to figure out something on the fly. Okay, so hopefully you can hear me. We'll just get started. So sorry, I guess there will be no video, but you'll be able to hear me and maybe I'll re record this so we can post one with with the videos. Okay, let's get going here.
So we had a few questions come in not too many, but we'll we'll get through them. All right, so somebody sent in a question asking if they could order the Merck Panicure granules 22%
222 milligrams per gram. So one pound containers instead of the individual packets like we sell so you apparently can buy the granules and a one pound container instead of the packets. So yes, that is absolutely fine.
You can order that and then obviously you'll just have to figure out how much I'm assuming they'll put in a scoop or something or they'll indicate.
The dosage so one packet of the fin bend is all that we sell each packet you get a minute box of three each packet is one gram. So you're going to want to, you know, adjust adjust the dose accordingly.
Okay, next question, red and an article that says this is a quote here, H, but so hyperbaric oxygen therapy increases the stem cell circulation by like eight times and also increases the oxygen concentration of tissue by like 20 times.
So that really turns on healing throughout the body. Can you help me understand I read on the Conner's clinic blog about the benefit of deoxygenating the tumor environment, but this, but is this increase in stem cell circulation only non cancerous or is this a risk for increasing cancer stem cell circulation.
I'm looking more into my veg F tumor suppressor genes, a tumor suppressor gene function and whether H, but is good to oxygenate or not because of increased tumor, tumor suppressor area.
Okay, so let's talk a little bit about hyperbaric oxygen therapy. So hyperbaric oxygen therapy is you get inside of a tube. It's 100% oxygen and then it's under pressure. So it forces the forces.
I admit people are joining in right now. Okay.
Okay, hello, everyone. I know some of you just jumped on and I apologize. I'm on a different computer and I, it's not letting me share the screen.
So it's just audio and I don't, I don't know how to fix it the second. So I apologize for that.
Let's see now I have to get back. Okay, so the question was regarding hyperbaric oxygen therapy and whether it, it's saying that it increases cell circulation. Does it increase just healthy cell does it increase cancerous, you know stem cells.
So hyperbaric oxygen circulation. So hyperbaric oxygen therapy.
It's 100% oxygen forces it into your tissue. It's under pressure. So you are going to oxygenate your tissue, your whole body is receiving oxygen.
You've always, you know, recommended it as a cancer therapy. It's different than what this person is referring to by not wanting to stimulate the veg F tumor suppressor gene, the veg F tumor suppressor gene that stands for Vascular vascular endothelial growth factor.
So what that is is sending basically veg F stimulates nitric oxide to increase blood vessels supply to whatever tissue it's trying to heal.
And so this is great for you know normal healing process, but of course we don't want to be stimulating veg F could increase angiogenesis or blood vessel growth to tumor cells. So we do not want that.
So if you've had your genetics interpreted by us and we've highlighted the veg F tumor suppressor gene, we've asked you, you know there's a couple of a few things that you can do. One of them is not to eat kale kale is high in nitric oxide.
So we don't want you to be having things that are high in ox nitric oxide. Again, because nitric oxide is helping to encourage the growth of the vascular system.
And in regular tissue healing that that's good. We need those blood vessels to supply that area to provide the healing nutrients to that area.
But again, we don't want that for cancer. So veg F and stimulating nitric oxide is different than hyperbaric oxygen therapy where we're just getting oxygen to the tissue.
Increasing blood vessel growth to the tissue, we're just oxygenating the tissue.
So that yes is helpful for healing, but it is not good for cancer, which is what we want. We want to create an environment that cancer doesn't like cancer thrives in a hypoxic environment. So a low oxygen environment.
So by by giving oxygen to that environment, we are doing something that cancer doesn't like creating an unstable environment for cancer growth.
It's a really good thing. So, you know, hyperbaric oxygen therapy is great for cancer. I'm sure, you know, just like I think Dr. Conner's talked about it in one of the last couple of zoom calls that, you know, taking one article or one study and then basing your decision off of that just one article, it's not good.
But honestly, you can probably find a study or article to support whatever your belief is. So, you know, looking at a few different articles, getting, you know, multiple opinions, which is exactly what this person is doing, getting our opinion. So that's great.
But then ultimately making making their own decision. So we like, like I said, we've always recommended hyperbaric oxygen therapy as great therapy for cancer patients as it's really good for some cancers like brain cancer.
The benefit of this comes in when you're doing it on a pretty regular basis. So one hyperbaric session is not likely to, you know, provide huge improvement or anything you need to kind of do it regularly to help oxygenate the tissue. So, so, you know, again, different from the veg F tumor suppressor gene. So you're not increasing veg F by using hyperbaric oxygen therapy.
Alright, next question. Is it possible that the five eight so may 18th program updates pushed me too far detoxed too quickly. So this person is referring to they had their original set of programs and then we sent out the update like we did for most of you probably received the update.
Some of you didn't need it. So they're asking because since they were running those programs, they have developed some gout, this person developed some gout in his knee. So he was experiencing some extreme pain turns out it's related to gout. So he's wondering, could I have detoxed too quickly.
Do we need to readjust the programs or just stay on the original. So it's possible to have detox really quickly the right is obviously program to target cancer cells. It's not necessarily directly killing cancer cells, but it's stimulating an immune response. So your body is alerted to those cells and it can go in and attack it.
So there could be some, yes, obviously there could be some tumor cell, some lysis. That's what we want is those for those tumor cells to die.
Do we need to readjust the programs or just stay on the original just stay with the programs with the new programs, the new programs are not that different. They're not different frequencies than the original programs.
Just organized in a different way. So the software can interpret it. So, you know, we may have condensed something some of you may have had, you know, a two or three week program and it may now just be a one week program. So we've condensed something. So in that from that perspective, you might be getting more frequencies specific to your cancer diagnosis or at least more time on those frequencies versus
older programs. So you, I mean, there it is possible that you could be detoxing too quickly because you could be, you know, potentially killing those cancer cells rapidly.
And so this person is saying in the past, I've heard that intense cellular breakdown can form uric acid is this true.
Do you think that the treatment was breaking down the cancer cells too fast and creating the uric acid build up that ended up creating out in the knee.
This is, it is possible. So uric acid is, you know, released upon tumor lysis, among other things. And the body does have to break that down and get rid of it. And so if your kidneys cannot keep up with that process.
If there is that excess and your kidneys can't can't keep up, then, then yes, we can have some symptoms of inflammation, you know, or potentially go so
I would think that this maybe wouldn't happen so much with the right. It might be more likely to happen if you were actually doing chemo therapy.
Because there's more cell die off and there is, you know, healthy cell die off when you're doing chemotherapy.
So in the five years that I've worked here, I haven't heard of somebody, you know, running their programs and then developing go certainly, you know, there, there's some inflammatory response that's desired.
It's not too specific to go in build up of uric acid. I haven't heard of that, but it's not.
Obviously out of the realm of possibilities certainly could happen and certainly if kidney function is not optimal that could also be a contributing cause.
I might want to get some lab work done to check kidney function, make sure everything is okay. They are certainly stay hydrated to help flush the system, decrease foods that can increase uric acid.
So animal protein, alcohol, I'm pretty sure that this person is not doing, you know, a lot of those things they're, they're aware and so not eating the things that can increase uric acid.
So I would say, you know, just like I said, stay hydrated, maybe do some lab work, certainly continue with the right.
You know, maybe, you know, do shorter amount of time, I don't know. I mean, I know this person took a break from the right and it is still experiencing some issues.
Dr. Connerns encouraged him to start it back up. So I'm not, I mean, we just don't know for sure if it's from the right for not and certainly the right therapy is targeted to help with cancer. So we, that's the priority.
So let us know if you do run some labs, send those in to our email address labs at Connerns Clinic dot com and we can check those out. Okay.
I do believe we are supposed to do another cheek swap at the end of July. Could you please send that.
So this I just put in here be as a reminder, the cheek swabs are available on our website. They're free of charge. There's no shipping charge. So you can go on our web store and just search cheek swab and place an order for them.
And they will obviously be shipped to your house. Certainly you can add it to any order of supplements that you're purchasing, but they are available on the web store.
So at any time you can order yourself some cheek swabs. We send out send them in a quantity of three.
But then also I wanted to remind people that you, your binder, we did send three cheek swabs in the front flap of the binder.
So you might already have some. So check there. If you don't have any, then you can certainly go to the web store and place an order for that.
And then they are asking, do you think that we will stay on the product, Pro to sell 23. If so, may I order two at a time versus one.
So you really are staying on your protocol until we do the retest and then depending on what comes up in retesting, you would either remain on it or not.
So I don't know the answer. I don't know if you will be remaining on it or not. We, we won't know until we complete that cheek swab testing again.
So I know obviously the protocol is very expensive. So I would just wait until we get to get that cheek swab and do the retest before you're ordering anymore and you certainly can order two at a time versus one.
All right. I realized that coffee animals are recommended. As I mentioned earlier, I don't believe I can do those without running into accidents happening. I move much too slowly right now. However, I have looked at the possibility of using essential oils in a carrier oil as a suppository in place of the coffee animals. It looks like
that could be a possibility. I realized that essential oils, the essential oils would need to be those that could be used internally. What are your thoughts on pursuing this approach.
So my thoughts are the reason that we're doing coffee animals are for two reasons. One of them is for detoxification. The other is to stimulate the vagus nerve.
And if you're not familiar with that, then look in your binder. There's a few pages talking about vagus nerve and vagus nerve exercises.
So coffee animals, right. So they're not for everyone. Some people physically just can't do them. Dr. Connors did create a video on kind of the lazy man's way of performing a coffee animal.
The instructions that we have sent that are in your binder are kind of the proper way to do coffee animals. But again, not everybody can do them the proper way. So go to the membership site.
And I know that Dr. Connors has put on there the lazy man's way to do a coffee animal and he'll walk you through that. And it does not involve, you know, lying down.
But, you know, you still have to go from one spot to the other to sit on the toilet to void. So that might still not be an option for you, but you might take a look at that and see if that would be something that would be a little bit easier.
And if that is not going to work for you, then certainly you could do an essential oil suppository. And, you know, just by inserting a suppository, you are getting some stimulation of the vagus nerve and depending on what oils you're using, you probably would be getting some detox benefit.
So I would also encourage you to look at again the vagus nerve exercises. And if you're not doing the animals, you can certainly do other things that are on that list, like gargling singing hot cold therapy.
So take a look at that list. And for the purpose of stimulating a vagus nerve, you might do some of those other things. I just don't know how much a suppository, you know, would stimulate the vagus nerve.
And I don't know how much it would allow for detoxing either.
The other option would be caster oil packs over the liver. So caster oil packs are known to stimulate the vagus nerve to help shift the nervous system into the parasympathetic branch, which is where we want you to be.
And that rest I just inhale branch. So calm, the nervous system. I guess I should say I don't know if it's actually stimulating the vagus nerve or if it is just another a different way to get you into that parasympathetic branch either case, the goal of stimulating the vagus nerve is to get you into that parasympathetic branch of the nervous system.
Caster oil packs, they do that they might not be doing it through stimulating the vagus nerve, but they do help you shift into that branch of the nervous system.
And caster oil packs over the liver do help with detoxification. So caster oil packs would, I guess, really be my my number two go to if you are unable to do coffee animals.
And then certainly you could do a suppository of essential oils, you know, once in a while and you're probably getting benefit from that as well.
All right, next question, I see that green tea is high in histamines. I have been taking green tea supplements EGCG. So because green tea is labeled being high in histamines, I have stopped taking them.
I have green tea as well and have ceased drinking it for the time being. It just seems like so many things that are good for fighting cancer are also high in histamines.
So remember the goal here is not to eliminate all things histamine. The goal is just to reduce the burden on the body.
And we're never going to be able to 100% eliminate histamines. That's not the goal. So the goal is just to reduce the burden.
So if we have told you or you tested for EGCG, then I would definitely still take it. EGCG is one of is something that can block the enzyme, the DAO enzyme that is necessary to break down histamines.
But I'm not sure. You know, I've seen that some studies saying that it actually doesn't. So it's kind of on this gray area of does it does it not.
I don't know what the right answer is. I've seen things saying it does block the DAO enzyme. And I just read something this morning saying that anything fermented teas will, you know, behind histamines because anything fermented is going to be good.
So don't do fermented tea, but the specific kind of tea leaf that creates the EGCG component is actually not high in histamines.
So I think that it maybe could go either way and yes, there is anti cancer properties to it.
You know, it does support some of the tumors suppressor genes. So I would I personally would still take an EGCG supplement, especially if it has been recommended by us based on your genetics or based on testing.
So I would still do that maybe just don't drink the green tea. So again, the goal is to reduce the burden not to eliminate it all together. So if you're eliminating most of the things that are in the high histamine list, that's great. You're reducing burden. So you can still take your EGCG. The other thing you can do
is take the DAO enzyme. You can take that in supplement form to, you know, break down histamines. So we use a product called histoclear provides you with the DAO enzyme.
So you can take that with meals or you can take that, you know, if you're drinking green tea and that again provides that enzyme to break break histamines down.
That actually brings us through the questions that came in. I don't know if anybody has any questions.
If you chatted any, you don't see any chats that came through, but certainly if you have any questions, you can send them in the chat. Hopefully, hopefully these things made sense for those of you that weren't quite on in the very beginning.
I just mentioned that I haven't had much sleep in the last two nights. So please forgive me if I seem off because I am my dog has been having seizures. She doesn't have a history of seizures.
But she had three grandma seizures in the last two nights. And so I've had very little sleep. It's very stressful to watch your little furry, furry love go through that. I can't imagine, you know, if you have kids with seizure disorders or, you know, a spouse or somebody obviously seizures are common with brain tumors. And so some of our brain cancer patients I'm sure have experienced seizures.
So not not fun, very heartbreaking. And so I am a little off today, a little sad and a lot exhausted. So hopefully my answers still made sense.
And part of the reason I can't figure out how to share the screen is because I'm on a different computer.
So any questions for me. And hopefully, if you did chat, I mean, wait, okay, I don't see any chat at the end. So let's see here, make sure I got everything.
So guys, don't see up here comes a chat. Oh, thank you. Sorry to hear about your dog. Yeah.
Gosh, it's just so sad to see the witness. And of course it was happening at night. So now every time she falls asleep, I'm nervous. I'm like covering over, but she'll be okay.
I'm more testing some more investigation to do this afternoon. So, but thank you. No fun.
She is old, you know, I mean, she is 13. So she's had a great life. So if this is the beginning of the end, then we've, we're prepared to just lover until, until it's time.
I had a bird that had seizures.
Sad, you know, it's so hard. Gosh, they're so little.
I'm getting ready to call to schedule a CT and pet scan. So all I take is the homeopathic to prepare for that.
And yes, that's all you have to take. We do have, we do have a radiation kind of full protocol that I can send to you kind of involving a few more things, certainly not necessary.
That's one thing we do recommend for sure would be the homeopathic dropper, but I can send you the radiation, the radiation protocol and you can do some of the additional things listed there, you know, goes for some extra wife programs, you can run some extra detoxing things that you can do.
Again, not, not necessary, but certainly you can take a look at that and do what you would like. So we're praying for you, praying that everything on the scans shows in your favor in our favor, we're praying for you.
So I will email that to you. If I forget, please email me and you can give me a little email, not if I forget, but my goal is to I'll send that to you as soon as we get off here.
Any other questions.
All right.
You don't see anything else coming in.
So you guys all wait, I was on platinum based chemo will, will the platinum detox from me. Yes, eventually it will, you know, it's a process. So we certainly have to make sure all phases of detox are working.
You can look at Dr Conner's book, the seven phases of detox. Certainly we're working on detox just from a cancer perspective, but there are some additional things that you can implement to help if you feel like you want to implement that.
And so yeah, yes, we can do some additional things and anything in the right that's related to detox can be helpful. So there is a search bar when you hit the open program button on your right software.
You can scroll and look through the list of things, but there also is a little search bar. Maybe you've seen it. I don't know if anybody has actually utilized that, but you can search for keywords.
And it will bring up a list of all of the right programs, including foot baths.
That you can run that have the word detox in it. The other thing that you can do is, you know, specific organ supports a liver support kidney support to help with detox as well. So you can find a lot of.
There are a lot of programs to help with detox, bulb programs and foot bath programs, certainly coffee, animals, caster oil packs, you know, gut health, making sure that you're not constipated. That's a big one.
The founders book, the seven phases of detox walks you through in great detail all of the phases and likely you're already doing a lot of the things mentioned in the book.
But if we need to, we can certainly support with some additional things.
All right, any other questions.
Thank you.
Can we get some rest? Yes. I mean, that mold where I can't sleep, even if I tried.
But that will pass. I think after our appointment this afternoon, hopefully I'll feel better.
At least we'll have some more information and go to bed.
You know, just getting some more information so we can assess and figure out the plan. So that will be helpful.
All right, well, everyone, I am going to sign off. I hope that everybody has a wonderful day.
And I apologize for not being able to share the screen. I'll get it figured out. So the next time I'm on this computer, it will work appropriately.
All right, you guys have a good day. Thanks. Bye bye.